this is my friend Joe Hey Joe where did
we meet we met on Grindr hey it's Paul
teacher for recent TV CPAC has done all
they can to push out gays officially
here at CPAC but we think they're still
here we're gonna try and find them we're
gonna try and do whatever we can to
track down the gay people here but where
do you find gay people at the
Conservative Political event of the year
we walked around for hours trying to
find them
bathrooms ballrooms the convention floor
but then it hit us where do you find gay
conservatives at CPAC there's a social
media app called grinder grinder where
you find gays all the time the gay
dating a networking smartphone app
Grindr that's us that's our Grindr
profile gay at CPAC question mark and
you message me and ask if I want to do
an interview do you identify as gay I
would have to oppose being honest yes
and see back behind the times well I
think so because I think in especially
for conservatives to be able to win an
election they're gonna need to get
younger voters seem to do that they need
to start being more socially liberal
essentially they need to shift
libertarian if we're true conservatives
we don't want the government to be
involved in our lives period I think
there are a lot more important issues we
could be talking about I wish the
Republican Party would focus more on
economic policy or other things like
that over gender issues why are we
talking like this what's going on
basically I am not comfortable with
putting myself out there publicly and
just to protect myself and others that
are associated with me we've been on
Grindr for a good two days now and we've
talked to a lot of different
conservative gay people that are just at
CPAC are you surprised by that I was a
little surprised by that you know on
Grindr
they're a lot of conservative men on
there and they are here it's just kind
of like what you see isn't always what's
actually going on are you surprised to
be at the amount of gay gay guys on
Grindr at CPAC actually I'm not I think
in society there's a lot more than
people on admit there's just a stigma so
most people just keep that to themselves
do you think rinder is a scary thing no
I think it's a wonderful thing I met a
guy and dated him for eight months on
Grindr yeah you know it's really
whatever you want to get out of it you
can get out of it
there's definitely been situations where
I'm a girl but someone I was just like
yeah this isn't this this is it I've
just been catfished I definitely think
you have to be careful I don't think you
can just give out information or talk to
anybody so you definitely have to be
smart I like creepy reporters right yeah
I mean it's a public place I'd I doubted
you would do anything creepy so reason
TV all Dietrich USA